welcome to this video josue afm now
Joe's wave vm let's see getting a Slav
defense okay for the main line this time
I want to do something else well yeah
you care that the possible line think 95
is one one thing one key moves might see
to check i can take because of made on
f7 but this is about anything that i
know about it that I can clone idea fire
and maybe playing for you for him can I
do that already i can go reform yeah
this is one of those setups where black
is not really trying to improve equality
but he certainly has a fairly simple
position to play aha see fire I teak
quinces 7 not probably trying to double
the tag here okay playing playing it in
a very simple way here just trying to
argue that ultimately and check this
Bishop is not great Queen before maybe
now not trading trading would help me a
little bit nothing brilliant but okay he
allows me to trade well let's do that
I'm just playing very simple chassis
hate to say it but this is kind of
illegal style just playing the the
simplest possible stuff I could have
taken a six year and I should have taken
a six why didn't I do that hmm ha it was
a mischance okay try to be to double
yeah I thought f4 would be good as it
isn't it knight c6 then on now but it's
not really that great film knight c6
Roxy form it's not bad
if it takes Bishop takes this Bishop
takes ease 6 threatened we shouldn't
forget that I definitely have the better
better King position also okay so let's
take that I go e5 isn't this just better
for me piano this is a big space
advantage and I've ripped the one route
d6 those kind of moves rook d1 or I mean
before would be nice obviously but c3
hangs broken t1 problem
so if i go to d aid she'll probably king
of 70 have this czechia winning a pawn
okay it's no reason not to check check
yeah but I can go to the phone alright
so let's check just be 41 be 44 be 5 or
is that some some other way to earn to
play here many end games are now really
really good okay this is an end game
already not being very precise here but
I mean even upcoming end games are
really nice before be 5s the idea now
trying to push the rook away from the
cover of the six point yeah last game I
was quick this game not so much p 5
let's check on c4
it's still problematic for him still a
problem check still threatening rupee
six and King f7 what check yeah look
look back was anna hasn't raised I
wasn't too convincing item here this am
as kind of thing here b5 it's kind of
good right I hope platform I thought
king of seven is what he has to do I
mean he cannot move this and rookie
sixes Israeli can remove the the night I
was gonna do this is a thought what this
is what I was expecting and he's now
tied to the b7 porn no I can just
improve a little bit like this but it's
not that easy he can still hang on the
issue here was I think he underestimated
the whole thing in this position Black
has to be a little bit precise simply
because of the fact this Bishop is not
playing and of course I mean here I can
just take a six and here i can just take
a six and that's it but yeah I didn't do
that like this yeah white is a little
bit better but nothing substantial maybe
G fire this I don't know maybe you
should really play um you should really
do do this I was thinking that this
might be something a little bit because
of my kingdom note that if we look at
this check this is quite nice I have the
King inflamed so he was he was not in
big trouble but it was still and
slightly tricky and he
this is now a problem the bishop him on
age 7 and this was directly act giving
away the porn job I think yarn estimated
this may be a little bit I had some a
little something and you had to be
precise as black okay well thanks for
watching